come on four dudes drunk and naked in
the hot tub that's straight Hot Tub Time
Machine okay so the premise of Hot Tub
Time Machine is pretty simple three guys
were best friends back in the 80s keep
in touch but they don't really hang out
anymore and so they all set out to go to
the ski resort that they went to back in
Winter Fest 86 along with John Cusack's
nephew you know rekindle the good old
times kind of thing but now in 2010 this
place is an absolute box I mean it
just looks horrible it looks like that
town from Book of Eli yeah there's just
no fun to be had there and so far the
only fun that they can muster they all
get hammered in this hot tub which
happens to be yes a time machine and so
they all get blasted back to Winter Fest
in 1986 then shenanigans and 80
shoutouts ensue no it is not often that
I like both movies that were released in
one weekend but in this case I really
did this movie was great it was
hilarious it didn't take itself too
seriously and if you're a fan of the 80s
or 80 shout outs you're going to laugh
your ass off in this movie I guarantee
it it's like the wedding singer with a
lot less heart that it makes it foreign
crudeness yeah it was a crude movie I
mean like I said it's not meant to be
taken too seriously so the fact that
John Cusack plays the same role in this
movie that he plays in every other movie
he's ever done there's only slightly
irritating but it is about 9,000 steps
up from 2012 yeah but John Cusack's
friends are really the ones that bring
this movie together I mean the white
ones a little bit of a douche but Darrel
from the office he's always funny you
can almost make a game of trying to
catch all the 80s references in this
movie or a drinking game now we're
talking like two people were fighting in
this movie in the background you hear
some guy go do a booty big that is
classic and there's some cameos in this
movie from some former 80s movie actors
one in particular that I did not even
recognize until halfway through the
scene not gonna tell you who it is
my dad died laughing now our time
travelers here have to be careful
because they know if they change one
thing could affect the entire course of
their lives are some butterfly effect
Doc Brown but the movie does touch
on the concept of if you can go back and
do things differently and do them over
would you I thought that was cool
because sure we've all thought about
that I thought about that so for my
money I laughed my ass off in this movie
I haven't laughed this hard since the
hangover honestly it's a fun irreverent
time where the fun's magnified if you
remember the eighties and if you do you
almost have to see this movie and no one
out there try to ruin it by being all
like well technically speaking there are
not enough tachyons contained in a hot
tub to pull you through what you can see
is time because they had something
better than tachyons they had Russian
Red Bull and 151
that punches your tachyons right in the
face that's right Russian Red Bull and
151 otherwise known as the cure for AIDS
or time travel so if you're looking for
a lot of laughs and crudeness does not
bother you go see this movie and if you
like this my review that is then
click here
[Music]